[hisses]
Certainly don't try to suck out venom,
because that's never really been shown
to improve the outcome of any snakebite.
I'm Dr. Cyrus Rangan.
I'm a medical toxicologist
with the California Poison Control System,
where I've been assistant medical director
for the past 20 years.
Today we'll be looking at
toxicology scenes in movies
and judging how real they are.
Who the h--- are you?
Hail Hydra.
What it looks like is
that he has a false tooth
that actually contains cyanide.
The concept of actually hiding
cyanide in a false tooth
seems to be a little bit more
folklore than it is fact.
And in fact, when you talk to people
at the National Spy Museum,
they'll tell you that
this is not something
that people really engaged in.
But did villains maybe back in, you know,
the time of Nazi Germany,
things like that,
did they use cyanide
capsules to commit suicide
so that they would not
be incriminated later?
Yes, that practice actually did occur.
There still are some problems with this.
The concept of the foaming
followed very quickly by death
is probably more theatrical
than it is expected symptoms
that you would see from
a scientific standpoint.
Is it possible that someone might have
some excessive drooling or foaming
while they're experiencing other symptoms
of cyanide poisoning?
Sure, that's possible.
But for that to be the only symptom
and then so quickly followed by death,
that's what gets a little
bit far-fetched here.
Cyanide, although it is a
relatively fast-acting poison,
meaning it doesn't take hours to kill you,
it still does take a few minutes at least.
And perhaps in that five-
to 10-minute period,
that's when death generally is seen.
I could give this somewhere
between maybe a 3 or a 4.
Qyburn here is the cleverest man I know.
Clever enough to learn
what poison you used
to murder Myrcella.
The Long Goodbye, was that it?
Qyburn: The Long Farewell.
That's the one.
Well, obviously, we are
not aware as toxicologists
of any poison that is even
nicknamed The Long Farewell.
So it sounds like it's entirely made up.
Cersei: How long does the poison take?
Qyburn: Difficult to say. Hours, days.
It depends on the subject's constitution.
But death is certain?
Qyburn: Oh, yes, your
grace. Quite certain.
If we are to go with his assessment
that this could take several hours
or perhaps days to kill you,
there are some toxins out in the world
that could act like that,
and the one that comes to
mind is the disease botulism.
And botulism is a disease that does work
relatively slowly from that standpoint.
The concept of putting
it on somebody's lips
and kissing that person
and then being able to neutralize that
with some kind of an oral antidote
is a little bit far-fetched.
When it comes to poisons
and antidotes or antitoxins,
it really depends on the poison itself
in terms of whether there is an antitoxin
or an antidote available.
It's not common that we would
have a very deadly poison
that you could take immediately,
and then give an antidote
immediately orally
that is suddenly going
to neutralize that poison
and limit its ability to kill you
if it's something that
would kill you otherwise.
For this one, I would probably put it
in the range of about 2 to 3.
I smell nothing.
What you do not smell
is called iocane powder.
It is odorless, tasteless,
dissolves instantly in liquid,
and is among the more
deadly poisons known to man.
For Westley to say that
it dissolves instantly
in any liquid is also a
little bit far-fetched,
because, for example, things
that dissolve well in water
don't dissolve well in
alcohol and vice versa.
So to say that it dissolves in any liquid
is something that probably goes
beyond the realm of science.
We're talking about a poison here
that kills someone very, very quickly,
and there aren't really many
poisons that can do that,
that can kill you within seconds
where you look just fine
and then suddenly die.
I spent the last few years building up
an immunity to iocane powder.
In general, when we're
talking about poisons,
these aren't things that you can really
build up an immunity towards.
You can build up immunity
towards infectious diseases,
but building up an
immunity towards a poison
is not something that we generally see.
There is a concept
that's called tolerance.
So, for example, with drug users,
they tend to require
higher and higher doses
of whatever drug of choice they use
in order to achieve their desired effect,
and that's a different kind of concept.
But the concept of immunity from a poison
is not something that we
would consider scientific.
I would probably give it a 3.
Peeta!
That's nightlock, Peeta!
You'd be dead in a minute!
I didn't know.
So, nightlock is fictional as
far as the name is concerned
and probably is derived from nightshade,
and perhaps they're
combining it with hemlock,
which is another poison.
But when you look at
those particular berries,
those look like what are called
Atropa belladonna berries,
which is commonly referred
to as deadly nightshade,
where you could get
dizzy, kind of confused,
a little bit loopy, and
possibly unresponsive.
And sometimes patients can be so severe
that they get seizures and coma,
and if you're going to die
from deadly nightshade,
that would be the reason.
Where it does fall apart
a little bit for me
is when she says that it
will kill you in a minute.
The bottom line is that you
should never, ever, ever
do your own foraging
unless you are a botanist
and someone who's well trained.
I'd probably put it around a 4.
[hisses]
When I was a kid, whenever we went hiking,
we always carried olive
oil and a razor blade
in case of a snakebite.
The depiction of this
particular snakebite wound
looked a little bit unusual to me.
Usually, a snakebite is
a subcutaneous injury,
where the fangs make
it down into the tissue
at or below the skin layer,
and then you start to
get a lot of destruction
of the tissue around that area
and a lot of inflammation
and subsequent swelling.
So you don't expect to see
that sort of voluminous bag of fluid.
Maria: So brave.
What we have learned, however,
over the last several decades,
is that cutting into a snakebite wound
is probably a very bad thing to do.
And we've seen many cases where people
actually introduce more
injury into the situation
than help the situation.
So people are cutting
into arteries and veins,
cutting into nerves, cutting into tendons.
So these are very bad
things that can happen
as a result of slicing into that wound.
So in general, we don't
slice into snakebite wounds.
Ah!
Mom: Good boy.
And we certainly don't
try to suck out venom,
because that's never really been shown
to improve the outcome of any snakebite.
In medieval times, people back then said
that you should coat
your lips with olive oil
and open the wound and suck out the venom.
And, again, this was
back from medieval times,
but unfortunately, a lot of
those kinds of treatments,
especially for envenomations,
carried over through the century.
The general rule of
thumb for any snakebite
is simply to get to a hospital
as soon as humanly possible.
There really is no other first aid
that you really need to do
other than to keep the patient calm
so you can be evaluated
and evaluated for the need for antivenom.
I would actually rate
the accuracy quite low,
somewhere between 0 and 1,
and simply because they are
talking about treatments
that could really make
a bad situation worse.
Castor beans.
Jesse: So what are we gonna do with them?
You're going to process them into ricin.
Ricin, of course, is a real toxin
derived from natural sources.
It actually comes from the
castor bean or the castor seed.
When you're ingesting ricin,
it causes mayhem in your
gastrointestinal tract.
So what's going to
happen is you're going to
experience extremely
voluminous fluid loss,
and it can be so severe that
it's impossible to catch up
by just simply drinking and
trying to replace those fluids.
And can it cause death?
Yes, it can, from all those fluid losses.
Walt: It's toxic in small doses.
Also fairly easy to
overlook during an autopsy.
And that's probably true, that if someone
was experiencing extreme
vomiting and diarrhea
and dehydration and then death,
ricin is not necessarily the first thing
that people would think of.
People would think more
about infectious diseases
causing those kinds of problems.
Walt: Kind of under the weather?
Like you've got the flu?
That would be the ricin I gave you.
Oh, my God.
There is no direct antidote for ricin.
It's really, the treatment
is what we call in
medicine supportive care.
So in other words, we
treat the bad symptoms
that occur from the
actual poisoning itself.
You know, she was on the phone
and conscious and, you know,
so if she was experiencing symptoms,
she probably was in the very early phase.
So she probably could
get herself to a hospital
and maybe get ahead of the poisoning
by making sure that she's
got IV fluids on board
as soon as possible
before the severe symptoms took place.
Yeah, it's entirely possible
that he's giving it away
a little bit too early for her
so that she could potentially
get treatment and survive.
As far as the scientific accuracy,
I would give this an 8.
Dealer: And fold.
It begins, of course, with Bond
drinking a poison from his glass.
What we learn later is that
this poison was digitalis.
Now, digitalis is a real poison.
It's a real compound.
But digitalis itself is available
in a number of different plants.
So there's a plant called foxglove,
another one called lily of the valley.
It's actually a medication,
and it helps the heart
pump more efficiently.
And when given under medical supervision,
under precise circumstances,
and we're checking drug levels,
it's a reasonable thing
to do for patients.
However, in large doses,
digitalis and other related compounds
can cause severe poisoning.
Some poisons can cause some major symptoms
with just a very, very small dose.
Digitalis probably would
not be one of them.
I would not expect digitalis in the form
of a couple of drops in a martini glass
and then after that is then, you know,
distributed throughout
the rest of the glass
and then a couple of sips later
you're suddenly experiencing
digitalis poisoning.
That's a little bit far-fetched.
And while it is true that if you instill
a concentrated salt solution
into your stomach very rapidly
it will likely make you vomit,
making somebody vomit after
taking a poison into the stomach
is actually not well
supported scientifically.
So this is not really a practice
that we espouse anymore.
So that's something where he was probably
really wasting his time.
Bond's been poisoned.
He's going into cardiac arrest.
Stay calm.
Ventricular tachycardia. Digitalis.
So now they have identified
the toxin in record time.
Now, that is a real
term, and that's a term
referred to the lower
chambers of the heart
uncontrollably beating very, very fast,
and that is something that does
require immediate treatment.
One thing that I could
say that they represented
more or less effectively
was the feelings that he was having,
the symptoms that he was having.
So it sounds like he was having
a pounding feeling in his
chest and some nausea,
and he's sweating.
Those are the kinds of symptoms
that you might expect
from digitalis poisoning.
Take the blue combi-pen, Bond.
Mid-neck into the vein.
That will counteract the digitalis.
They have him inject
something into his neck.
The term "combi-pen" is something that,
it's a simply made-up word.
I'm just hazarding a guess that
lidocaine is what they used,
because that is something
you can inject into people
who have ventricular
tachycardia from a poisoning.
But as I mentioned before,
it's got to be given
under very well-supervised circumstances.
Now get yourself off to a hospital.
Bond: I will do.
As soon as I've won this game.
If you have any poison on board
that's causing an abnormal heart rhythm,
yeah, you want to restore the
heart rhythm back to normal,
but that doesn't cure you of the poison.
But what he actually needs
is the real treatment for digitalis,
which is digitalis-specific antibodies,
and that actually is the
first-line treatment.
It is a little bit unbelievable
that he's not rushing
to a hospital right now
to get that key treatment
that he actually needs.
Probably give this about a 3.
Jellyfish sting!
Oh, it hurts, it hurts, it hurts!
Well, there's really only
one thing you can do.
What? What is it?
You're gonna have to pee on it.
What I think they really did get right
is the fact that jellyfish stings
tend to impart immediate pain,
and it's quite severe for
a lot of people as well,
depending on how much of the
jellyfish tentacle got on you.
Where I think it falls apart
is when it comes to the treatment.
It's long been folklore
that you should urinate
on a jellyfish sting.
There is no scientific backing to it.
You simply use the seawater to wash off
any remnants of those tentacles
that may still be on the site.
Those remnants include
tiny little cell-like
bags called nematocysts.
If they remain on your skin,
they can still discharge,
and so we like to use
salt water, essentially,
to cleanse those off gently.
So, urine has the potential
to be able to accomplish that too.
You're better off just using the seawater
than peeing on yourself.
If you put fresh water
onto a jellyfish sting
where those nematocysts
are still on your skin,
they can discharge under
conditions of fresh water.
So if your urine perhaps is
too dilute at that moment,
you could actually
discharge those nematocysts
and cause more pain.
In a lot of cases, urinating on yourself
probably won't make
things too bad for you.
It probably won't help,
but in certain situations,
it could make things worse.
This is not a good illustration
about what to do afterwards.
I would give this around a 6.
Kitai: Dad, I can't feel my hands!
Cypher: The poison is
affecting your nervous system.
Stay even.
An insect sting or insect bite
that could result in the depression
of the central nervous system,
that's probably not going
to happen from most things
in this sort of immediate
fashion that we're seeing here,
within seconds or within minutes.
There is actually a disease
called tick paralysis,
where there's a certain kind
of tick, a hardback tick,
that actually has a neurotoxic venom
that's injected in very,
very tiny amounts into us
but can actually cause
full-body paralysis.
But the tick has to latch onto you
and stay there for several
hours, perhaps even a day.
So there is that real possibility
that, yes, an insect
could give you paralysis.
Would it happen this quickly?
I don't think so.
Inject yourself directly into your heart
with the first stage.
Do it now.
We give the liberty that this
is a science-fiction movie
and that there is some
fictional superbug out there
that is causing this paralysis.
But would we have a situation
where we thought a neurotoxin
injected from a bug
would need to be treated by
an injection into the heart?
That's where things fall
apart for me as well.
If you had, for example,
an allergic reaction
to, let's say, a beesting,
you could still also give
intravenous epinephrine
by putting it into a vein.
But if you didn't have that access,
you didn't have the ability to set that up
and time's ticking away,
you can make the argument
that you could give
an epinephrine shot
directly into the heart.
And that actually is the initial treatment
we would give for nerve-agent exposure.
It would be atropine
directly into the heart.
So, yes, there is an argument to be made
for intracardiac injections
of certain medications
in very specific circumstances,
but certainly not for an envenomation.
I'd probably put this in
the range of about 0 to 1.
I'd say the one that's most
scientifically accurate
was the one from "Breaking Bad."
They used good, correct terminology
and gave an illustration of
what is supposed to happen
to a person under these circumstances.
The most fun to watch, I
think, was "Princess Bride,"
as I think it is for most people.
If you enjoyed this video, click
the link above for another.